we are stuck in a post-enlightenment
Failte to pure cartesian logical reason
we're smart we're at the peak of
evolution we have this powerful ability
to think to paraphrase Ambrose Bierce
from the devil's dictionary however the
reality is and there's lots of science
about this the brain is only the organ
with which we think we think it's job is
not to win Nobel prizes and to pass math
tests its job is to get us to tomorrow
it's a survival machine and it plays a
lot of tricks with the facts in order to
get us to tomorrow that worked pretty
well when the risks were lions and
tigers and bears in the dark oh my it's
not as good now when we need to
rationalize and reason and use the facts
more with the complicated risks we face
in a modern age climate change and
Donette eclis modified food and
unsustainable living on the planet and
that takes a lot more thinking kind of
cognitive slow more effortful thinking
that we are not instinctively built that
way must be recognized if we're going to
get beyond the risks of not being built
that way it would be ultimately rational
and reasonable for the rationalists and
the Cartesians to accept what the
science now tells us which is the brain
is only B organ with which we think we
think and there's a lot of subjective
mess that goes into the decisions we
make that often fly in the face of the
facts we better accept that and
understand it so that we can apply that
in order to avoid the pitfalls of our
subjective way of perceiving the world
right if we know why we get it wrong if
we know what subjective influences that
Daniel Kahneman and Paul slovic and a
whole lot of really smart people have
figured out about why our judgments
don't match the facts
know why we're irrational more than just
accepting that we are the evidence says
we are but if we know why we can use
those insights to say whoops that's why
we're making this mistake about X or Y
or Z and avoid the dangers of making
that mistake our brain is hardwired and
the chemistry of the brain guarantees
that we feel first and think second and
that's initially when we encounter
information but in an ongoing basis
between the facts and the feelings in
our brain the feelings carry more weight
when the feelings are I feel wonderful
but they might be wrong recognizing that
they might be wrong here's what you can
do take more time if the brain jumps to
conclusions out of emotion first and
more and there's plenty of science on
this just assume that your first
decision might not be the most informed
one don't leap to conclusions make up
your mind quickly take more time a half
an hour an hour a day to think about it
cogitate on it get more information get
more information not just from sources
who already tell you what you know and
believe because that's just going to
reinforce what you know which will feel
great but may not add to your knowledge
but take more time and get more
information and that allows that
information and the facts side of this
dual system to play more of a role let
me give you an example
vaccines let's let's take there's a
relatively new vaccine HPV vaccine human
papilloma virus vaccine for young pre
sexual aged daughters and they're now
actually recommending it for boys too
some versions of the virus or a scourge
cause of cervical cancer and other
sexually transmitted diseases well the
first reaction many people will might
have is to the word vaccines that's got
a whole stigmatized oh right
that's a natural emotional first
subjective protective way the brain is
going to react to vaccines if you just
went with the reaction right
it isn't as informed as looking up
what's the prevalence of cervical cancer
amongst girls in your demographic your
age group your gender your neighborhood
your your your walk of life that would
be interesting in helpful information
what are the side effects of the vaccine
find out I'm not making up your mind for
you about the vaccine but do you see how
instinctively your first reaction to
vaccines uh-oh starts to broaden against
the subjective pitfalls of maybe getting
it wrong if you give yourself more time
and get more information know that the
brains instinct is to make quick
decisions and to lean on instinct and
effect and emotion first to make them
and that might get you into trouble as a
tool for making healthier choices and
the quick simplest handy way to do that
is give yourself more time get more
information from trustworthy sources and
let the facts side of your reasonable
reasoning rationale great computer up
there play more of a role in the
decisions you make